[Music]
what are your plans for
valentine's day eating at home
what are you looking at i'm just looking
i'm just like what are your plans for
valentine's day joe
oh [ __ ] what are you doing for
valentine's day joe i uh
i i'm actually going to be out of town
what are you doing for valentine's day
you're kind of a little jealous i'm just
wondering what he's doing
for valentine's day the the what's your
guys's couple name again well apparently
nothing now it's no
oh yeah no that's what it is well here's
the thing
i'm um in love with my
stripper and i got
i got mushroom duties to do what had
happened was
he decided to find himself in some
mushrooms
i found myself and i realized that uh
i i don't i don't uh what do you call it
i'm not a regular human being
and i i i'm one of those guys that get
in like fall in love with objects and
stuff
oh well you forgot the name you should
be on that one show my strange addiction
yeah because we were like you must be
crazy joe you have this like beautiful
girl right here and you're not doing
anything and i'm like okay in a mushroom
i'm not a mushroom not a mushroom farm
why do i spend way more time with
mushrooms than i do with nikki because
she ate a fungus
sheena fungal you know what i mean
i'm sorry wait you hate puns that was
great i do but it just came out
that was good look at his face he starts
stuttering
his face turns red i just i'm sorry i'm
sorry i just don't want you to feel less
than
we both it's not just one-sided i didn't
follow through either
oh maybe in another lifetime right the
one that got away you know yeah so
what's up with valentine's why are you
asking me these well uh adding something
are you
gonna surprise me something right now oh
wow everybody's just getting through
yeah well
you guys can't go nowhere ah turning red
red
let's get that five dollar chicken from
college let's go
oh yeah we did by the way our mushroom
mushrooms our mushrooms are all bloomed
sweet yeah yeah i think i might have
might have waited too long though
before uh harvesting it's it's turning
oh okay upside down over look you could
harvest it again
do another yeah we'll do another round
do another round valentine's day yeah
anyways
valentine's day in san antonio
at the zoo specifically uh well since
nobody can go visit the zoo
the zoo is trying to figure out ways to
bring in some income so
they can't visit the zoo out there
pandemic pandemic panda
diego's opened up different rules
different states different counties
yeah i know but we're super close too
true the gorillas have cobit over there
so oh they got covered now oh man oh
yeah yeah they are testing animals for
covet and zoos
what's up didn't the tiger get coveted
and dogs can detect it
really dogs can get it too that's why
they can get it and detect it
what do they do when they find it they
go
i wonder if they can they lose their
taste too wait do they catch them
do they catch it just talk if they smell
it the useless dog
yeah they need people to hump you yeah
that's actually the test i got it
that's all off topic but yeah so the san
antonio zoo
is offering the chance to uh for five
dollars
for you to name a cockroach
after your ex wait and then they're
gonna feed that cockroach to an animal
and you get to watch it be torn get over
your ex
just kidding dude that's so funny it's
so
pity that it's like funny that a zoo
would come up with this
i know i i find it kind of vicious it's
funny a little it's a little uh
i don't know it's pretty trolly not kind
of they're causing more trauma in these
people's lives
i don't picture i'm very family friendly
a straight up like
zoo doing this and that's why it just
seems so
i don't know how do you picture doing
this i feel like i'm having deja vu
i swear i swear i've heard this story
before i swear
really really i've heard this story zoo
offering you a chance it's not a zombie
but it was something
else and it was like naming a cockroach
no i've seen one where it's like a pet
shelter
is like you could name a kitty litter
after your ex and you can watch
cats take a [ __ ] in it oh i heard the
cockroach i don't know i definitely feel
i
feel like i've heard something similar
but it wasn't a zoo
it was some cockroach farmer i don't
know some weird thing don't be doing
weird [ __ ]
because do they write the name the
cockroach i don't know how they feel
like
when you buy a star oh yeah yeah yeah
that's your starting them too
uh two birds reptiles or mammals oh they
eat cockroaches
literally this is just them trying to
monetize
the actual job yeah they do anything
yeah and they're
they're gonna live stream this too so
you get oh that's kind
that's really messed up you have to zoom
in on this and it's like hunger games
there's my ex could you now they're
being crunched what if you were in a
relationship with somebody and they did
that
how romantic yeah you go together and
you go buy a cockroach
it's like if it's like you're together
with army hammer it's like ooh
eat army hammer some cannibal [ __ ] first
off you want to break up with him
because that guy's a
he's a steal also i i don't know what
type of weird [ __ ] youtube be doing
we can use it
[Laughter]
i thought they were gonna do something
romantic like for this valentine's day
you can ride our elephants if they can't
have people there remember
they're not trying to gather people
together quarantined privately kind of
like how they you could book out the
movie theater
oh that's cute hey we need money here's
my gofundme link
yeah yeah here's my only fans page feed
the gorillas
animals yeah yeah only mammals
oh yeah i like it i guess it's more for
like singles awareness day you know how
like you know if you're single during
valentine's it's singing well
valentine's day is the most uh
suicide rates really yeah i just saw
cause people
go on a date and they're like i can't
take this [ __ ] no more like yeah
okay that's why the dates no don't go on
dates and then that's why you buy a
cockroach instead
see there we go easy fix express
yourself stick through cockroaches
sad cause they're lonely yeah i think so
i'm
true she's like i don't know i'm married
i don't have that [ __ ] problem i
can't relate
you know i don't know so we did an
article
i'm sorry i don't quite understand what
you're saying right now it doesn't apply
to me
yeah you know how we did that article of
like single people are happier
and then like and then they're like oh
valentine's day single people are sad
and it's like
make up your mind because your [ __ ]
mind statistics one day
it's seasonal get through it it's
different groups of people that we're
talking about
grass is greener too i feel like you
know in some cases and i feel like the
happiness also kind of manifests itself
when you least expect it
one thing wow because i could be happy
in a relationship and i could be happy
single like
why does what you do have to be your
happiness
and you can be miserable in a
relationship and you can be miserable
single
oh yeah we know so happiness is within
right joe
oh yeah you are in control of your
happiness
you can make your own happiness is a
skateboard going downhill
exactly no it's not cause i don't skate
very well and that would be like
that'd be very sad i don't even know
what that means
yeah you sit on the skateboard like this
together
get that long board perfect perfect for
two there's no pranks
yeah but if for five dollars a cockroach
doesn't do it for you
you could pay twenty dollars wow and get
a frozen rat named
uh after your ex and you can feed that
to your you're just doing the most
if you're spending money on your ex
though i know that's not like get over
it are you still
thinking would that make you feel better
though like if you did that
would you be like oh man i'm over my ex
now nothing you might as well make a
voodoo dog at that point
that's [ __ ] crazy actually don't make
a i don't know or even if i saw like
no they might be onto something that
might be a better use of your time i
mean twenty dollars yeah that's a lot
what for wraps expensive even if i
wanted to do that i mean twenty dollars
i'd rather buy a game stock go buy
yourself something nice
with 20 bucks or snx while you still can
maybe that is spending on themselves no
but it's
spending money on petty spikes
unhealthiness in there yeah it's
creating more knowledge
what they say is like trying to destroy
your enemies with hate is like
trying to kill and attack people by
poisoning yourself exactly
see there it is you're drinking poison
saying ha i got you [ __ ]
yeah it's like you didn't really hurt
any enemy
like your ex is gonna care that you
named uh by the way the other day i
bought a [ __ ] cockroach and uh
fed it to an animal yeah if you named it
you [ __ ]
you're like okay look at that number and
then they'll do that some toxic ass
people
yeah yeah yeah but you know what though
the zoo is smart because there are a lot
of petty ass people and they're like oh
[ __ ] yeah dude zoo knows what they're
doing oh yeah
instead it should be like oh name this
cockroach after your worries like uh
[ __ ] taxes like i don't know that's
pretty good
okay that seems constructive i like okay
i have to get crushed that's tight
that's like when you go to the japanese
temples and they have all the paper
things
yeah like this is my wish i want the a
plus
so burn stuff and stuff yeah they should
do that at the zoo all the kids at home
just burn stuff and stuff no don't do
that yeah not kid no kids
no teens teens is fine right no don't do
that yeah don't fire
no don't don't do that it's it's
spiritual it's like uh
that's it's a cleansing right don't you
think what it's therapeutic yeah control
i'm not saying
are you i don't i think i might be soon
yeah you're gonna switch over
yeah because it matches what i'm wearing
that side is there
that matches what i'm wearing it's
convenient i'm trying to be fashionable
you know
fashion forward fashion forward joe kind
of zen so yeah
it's also my call love's not on the menu
right now so you're like i'm just gonna
focus on me and just find happiness
within that's tight yup what are you
what are you gonna do for valentine's
day i'm gonna take my
first quarantine valentine yeah i think
we're gonna go to the beach
and uh that's probably it make it on a
beach and [ __ ] take her to the piano
we're gonna scam in the parking lot
didn't use that word but we'll be like
we're gonna go
yeah yeah that's kissy yeah yeah yeah
but like passionately kissing
scamming scamming scamming means
passionately kissing
yes but it also means like scamming
someone like you're a con artist oh yeah
that's the common name that's a little
but that's why i'm confused we're gonna
write some some false checks soul
counseling
it's weird that's all good but you're
scamming the person you're like i'm
gonna kiss you and do all this stuff and
then no relationship
i think it's like you're both gonna buy
some cockroaches you know what i mean
both doing something like forbidden so
it's like a scam
yeah you guys never do that pulling a
scam right now yeah yeah
a lot to the view you know when i'm
going to the beach you're a romantic ass
dude man no outdoor dining i don't think
so
oh yeah there is outdoor dining outdoor
dining's finally back in socal by the
way
what are you guys gonna do for for
valentine's day i don't know it's
valentine's day sneaks up on you you
know
he's planning something he's playing
it's always like i don't think we even
really celebrate valentine's day
really like it's not really a thing we
do
yeah or at least three days in the early
days it was like oh tasty
reciprocate because you do give me some
flowers sour
what do you get for what do you get for
casey that's what i just said i'm like
[ __ ] i guess i should receive
she gives to him you don't know what she
loves
come on thank you i mean guys are simple
you could take the same thing no but i
can't birthday
christmas all presents he's like don't
buy me [ __ ] i know it's the same thing
up to the room like him anytime kind of
guy
physical touch things but they're not
things that we can actually
post on social media yeah so that's why
i'm like i guess i should reciprocate in
a way where
you can also like so people know that
you're not just putting down on
valentine's day oh we can put your gift
but if that's your style though that's
your style
not only just true true yeah it's funny
when girls like don't you want more than
that and it's like nah that's perfect
keep it as is that's cool i'm like cool
i get out of it too
look at you
[Music]
you